وفي مقطع مصور بعثه على منصه جلوس سوشل
اكد الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
ان اداره بايدن تستهدف او تستهدفه لانه
يتقدم في نتائج استطلاع الراي في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه
هم يلاحقونني لاننا نتقدم الان في
استطلاعات الراي بفرق كبير على بايدن
والمرشحين الجمهوريين والطريقه الوحيده
لايقافه هي استخدام هذه الحرب ولا يمكننا
السماح بذلك بلادنا في طريقها الى الجحيم
وبعد نهايه ولايته قاموا باستخدام وزاره
العدل ومكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي كسلاح لا
يمكننا السماح باستمرار ذلك لان بلادنا
تتفتت نواجه مشاكل كبيره وقضيه ليست واحده
منها
كما شدد ترامب على انه سيثبت براءته مره
اخرى مضيفا ان الولايات المتحده تعيش حاله
انحدار
انا رجل بريء ولم افعل اي شيء خاطئ سنحارب
ذلك مثل ما فعلنا على مدار السبع سنوات
سيكون من الرائع لو كرسنا وقتنا الكامل
لجعل امريكا عظيمه مره اخرى وهذا بالضبط
ما فعلناه لكن البلاد في حاله تدهور ونحن
امه فاشله انا رجل بريء وسوف نثبت ذلك مره
اخرى ونحن نضع امريكا في المقام الاول